around 100 years ago the field of
physics was turned on its head by the
discovery of the laws of quantum
mechanics since then with ever improving
technology physicists be able to explore
in increasing detail the quantum world
we're uncovering more the powerful and
sometimes bizarre laws of quantum
physics at the forefront of this
endeavor is a field of ultracold atoms X
to understand what ultracold atomic
physics is we need to understand what
quantum mechanics is quantum mechanics
are the if you will the rules that the
game that describes how atoms behave how
single particles of light photons behave
so on and so forth so what is quantum
mechanics quantum mechanics is a theory
which describes the world on a
microscopic level and the most
fundamental consequence of this is that
properties like energy and momentum come
in packets and each packet is called a
quantum so this leads us to the
counterintuitive conclusion does a
quantum mechanical particle can only
move with certain amounts of energy
certain certain values of energy certain
values of momentum whereas on a
classical level a man can walk very
slowly or sprint very fast and there's a
continuum of states between those two
extremes because the laws of quantum
mechanics apply to very smallest things
now universe we need to work very hard
to isolate these atoms and to cool them
down to incredibly low temperatures in
order to do this we need to put them in
a trap and these are either made by
magnetic fields or by using lasers so
when we call these atoms - these ultra
low temperatures we use 20 units to talk
about their temperature we use you
insert Kelvin they're the same size as a
degree Celsius but they have a lower of
women zero Kelvin nothing to be colder
than zero Kelvin so the things we cool
we cool down the temperatures that are
100 nano Kelvin which means 100 billions
of a degree above absolute zero which
means
it's nothing because it's covering
anything you can imagine we need to call
these essence down to temperatures far
lower than any fridge that exists and so
we need to use completely different
techniques so the first stage is laser
cooling and then the second is
evaporative cooling and this is rather
hat like how your coffee calls so what
happens is that the hot air atoms are
ejected from the trap leaving behind
atoms at lower and lower temperatures so
once we have the atoms cooled and
contain we'll be able to literally see
the quantum properties and in fact a
number of remarkable quantum phenomena
will appear a clear example of that is
the phenomenon of Basel Einstein
condensation which has been predicted by
buzzer and Einstein in 1924 and found
experimentally in 1995 seventy years
after the prediction this has been done
at Jilla by Eric Cornell and Kurt
Wainman and at MIT by Volgin Catelli and
this work got the Nobel Prize in 2001
but I think condensation a bose-einstein
condensate is a new form of matter which
forms at very low temperatures and it's
a consequence of wave particle duality
what I mean by that is that all
particles in nature atoms or lights they
sometimes have waved my properties and
sometimes have part of the light
properties as you cool and act them down
it's its properties become more and more
wave-like as it gets colder and colder
its wavelength gets longer and longer
and eventually if you have a group of
atoms together eventually you reach a
point where all of the wavelengths start
to overlap and you form one giant Matter
wave and the whole group of atoms starts
to behave like one wave and that's
called a bose-einstein condensate we're
developing new world-leading techniques
in order to be able to control and
manipulate quantum matter these
techniques are enabling us to find novel
quantum phenomena within the ultracold
atoms well okay so we've got one
an exam you know it describes how small
chunks of matter or small chunks of
light how they behave we needed to
understand that behavior but what's it
good for
is it only good for explaining what's
already out there or is it something
that we can leverage you can use to do
completely new things and one of the
most exciting new developments I think
in the in that field of say quantum
optics is the discovery that if you can
actually build machines that are
governed by quantum physics then you can
do things that are completely impossible
with classical machines the quantum
physics of many many particles is at the
center of some of the most intriguing
phenomena in in solid-state physics
which also have enormous technological
applications if you could further
development and understand and better
code rational physics is producing
entirely new technology based on quantum
physics and this is going to provide
impact outside of physics and
engineering
you